what we're doing is of course investing
massively in the police when i saw the
steps of downing street
two years ago i said i wanted another 20
000 officers on the streets of our
country
and we've now got to we're almost half
the way there we're putting
15.8 billion into supporting our police
but
of course it's been a tough time
financially for the whole
country we've had to deal with the costs
of the pandemic about 407 billion pounds
supporting jobs and
livelihoods across the country what
we're now seeing today is plans to
to back the police but also to back the
public so that if you're the victim
of a crime you have a named police
officer
uh that you could go to wherever you
live uh who will attend you
and who will make sure that we deal with
the police deal
with your crime and now the point of
that is yes they do that
in some parts of the country already but
what you need is somebody who
understands what's going on in your
neighborhood who understands who the
likely
miscreants are who can understand
whether the thing that you're reporting
the crime that you're experiencing
is a one-off or part of a trend and who
can really help
to deal with it we're also backing the
uh the police with
uh with more body-worn cameras with more
tasers and more protections against
those who
who assault uh police officers uh in the
course
of their duty um prime minister why are
you relaxing the rules on stop and
search
when you know there are huge concerns
about the discriminatory aspect of this
especially among black communities and
while there's limited evidence of
whether this policy even works
well i i disagree with the opponents of
of stop and search and section 60
uh stop and search orders i think can be
play an important part
in fighting crime i want to stress a
chap that they're not the only
tool that we've got to use uh they're
part of a range of things we've got to
do
to fight street crime but i think giving
the police the
the backing that they need in law to uh
to to stop someone uh to search them uh
to relieve them of a dangerous
weapon uh i don't think that's a um
strong arm tactics i think that's a kind
and a loving thing to do
the people who are who often support
stop and search most passionately
are the parents of the kids uh who are
likely themselves
to be the victims of knife crime so i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna
give in on that we've got to make sure
that we back our police with with proper
powers for stop and search
we've had 11 years of conservative
government and anti-social behaviors at
its highest level for seven years
how can your party claim to be tough on
crime when the stats show that you're
just failing
what the statistics on crime now show is
that neighborhood crime is down about a
third
homicide down about 16 uh serious crime
serious violence down
11 but look i'm not i'm not going to
rest on those statistics because
yes i do think that the lock down has
driven some
antisocial behavior and we need to deal
with it
and uh we that's why we're backing uh
the police in in the way that
we are but i also want to see those who
are guilty
of anti-social behavior properly
are paying their debt to society and you
know
somebody's anti-social behavior may be
treated as
a minor crime but it can be deeply uh
distressing
for those who are victims and if you're
guilty of anti-social behavior i don't
see
and and you're sentenced to to do unpaid
work as many people are i don't see any
reason why you shouldn't be out there
in one of those fluorescent jacketed
chain gangs
visibly paying your debt to society so
what you're going to be seeing more of
that as well